welcome to the data science hangout
i'm rachel dempsey
you're a host for today and welcome back
to
all the familiar faces i've seen here
the past few weeks
but for anybody who's just jumping on
for the first time
there's no agenda for these sessions
it's really just focus on questions that
are most important to you all
so you could jump in live or put
questions in the chat and we do also
have a slido link so if you want to ask
any anonymous questions you can do that
as well
and robert i'll have you put the slide a
link in the chat if that's okay
and just a heads up though this session
will be recorded so we'll share the
recording up to youtube
and then we take some helpful like two
minute snippets and share those up there
as well
but i'm joined by my co-host for today
uh
co-host and friend from the boston usar
group brian butler who's a vp of
business insights and analytics
and has been on a few of these sessions
so far
but brian i'd love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe share a bit about
your team and the work that you do
sure hey thanks rachel and thanks
everybody for for joining up
um
so i have a very small team team two
myself and and one other uh
sort of junior data scientist guy
uh we support
pretty much the whole organization uh
and
we're in the early stages so
uh
company has only been doing something
like data science and i won't call it
completely data science for only about
18 months
so it's really really getting started
and mostly focusing on supporting the
marketing department
but i do a lot of work for our president
and the board
um
and you know we're trying to just really
get started with innovation how do you
how do you use data science
in these traditional type roles and
um
one of the things i just want to talk
about that is i often see on linkedin
how do i get a job in data science how
do i get started
uh
and i i always tell people it's easier
to bring data science skills to a
regular job in marketing ops finance
than it is to get that first job
listed as a data scientist and
of course everybody's always going for
your famous tech companies and
everything else so those jobs are even
you know more one in a million more
lottery ticket type
stuff
so that's a little bit about what we do
so my career has been the most direct
path you can get into data science
started in the military
worked in chemistry
uh
then went into insurance as a quantum
risk trader
uh ran my own business for a while as a
restaurant restauranteur
uh
was an independent contractor and then
got into data science as you can see it
is the most direct group as i always
tell people
and uh
i didn't know you had a restaurant
i said i didn't know you had a
restaurant
yeah yeah i was uh i left the corporate
world
in uh 2010
uh
after actually we had lived in bermuda
for a couple years that's why i was
doing the risk trading came back
did a year in the corporate world one
more year and i was like i'm tired of
this i'm tired of the commute
uh
let's chase a passion and our passion
was food and wine so so that's what we
did we
um
took a departure and did that for a
couple years actually
um
and i would never do it again
people come up and say oh that's so
exciting i really want to do it i'm like
no you don't
and uh
you know even now like i think about it
now and with coven and everything i'm
not sure my business
would have survived uh
it was
hair raising and knuckle bra knuckle
white knuckling off
uh without covered going on back in 2010
11 12 13.
um
so i really feel for for the for the
people in that industry and what's going
on out there and and understand what
they're really going through
um
and it's hard
but uh
i think one of the things that's been
key to all of this
when i when i look back at it is
this passion for learning
um
and even now like i am
constantly i i'm literally constantly
taking classes and learning
um
i think i'm enrolled in like four online
classes now and
uh i actually
am enrolled in a curriculum for computer
vision which is great because we start
from ground zero
and it came from
along the way
i became obsolete and it's kind of scary
and
it was after my restaurant business so i
was like all right let's get back into
the corporate world let's do
um
do some stuff
and
uh i just finished some contracting work
also but there was a big break and i was
applying for jobs and people were like
do you know r you know sas
uh and i was like no
but i could do the job as a sense like i
you know it was the jobs insurance
industry so it's like yeah i know the
statistics i know the actuarial i know
your specialty lines i used to
you know run the products and things
like that but people were just like
no
we need we need a modern skill set and
it took me about
eight months to find that job um
and it was scary i'll be honest with you
it was just um
you know this sinking feeling and
um you know i've talked to people about
it along the way
uh that have gone that are going through
the same thing
and um
but i you know i did i i actually took
the coursera curriculum from johns
hopkins the r course
uh which is i think it's like 12 courses
or something like that and
i crammed through it in about three or
four months
and that's what landed me a job
to be able to go on to an interview and
and talk a lot more about that
um
and it was with a startup
so it was a uh
sort of the i call it my first step to
reintroduction to
uh the corporate world and that was back
in 2014.
so you think that it was
primarily the the languages that you
started to learn through coursera that
that helped or were there other pieces
from like i can imagine you have a very
unique skill set from all these
different
experiences
it was um
it was a couple of things so there was a
lot of that experience because it was
actually an insurance startup
um
but i was totally not hired to do that
at all
which is kind of funny um that's not
what they were hiring for but i think
taking the courses
helped connect all the dots
that i had spent the last 12 years doing
um
you know i i
took phd level courses in time series
when i was in graduate school so i i had
that time series background and used it
a lot um
i think it's one of the most
underutilized or under focused skills
out there like real time series not just
oh i use facebook profit or i use automl
and it spits out some results
um
and understanding that you know the
funny thing was i was doing predictive
analytics
for a while and it was actually data
science like i was using you know linear
regression and doing
data holdouts and logistic regression so
when i was talking to these guys in the
interviews they're like
yeah you've done all this you're doing
all this stuff and i was like well i use
the r language and one of the guys that
was that was an interview he was
yeah hugely into art he's a good friend
of mine still to this day uh we still
geek out every once in a while but uh
it definitely moved the needle and
made it happen um
i see alyssa had a question and alyssa
feel free to to jump in and introduce
yourself as well
um but a question around was that
coursera our series from jeff leake yep
yep that was the
the three guys from johns hopkins jeff
was one of them and i can't remember who
the other two were
um
basically my favorite people on the
planet
[Laughter]
that's awesome i learned a huge amount
and that's actually almost before the
tidy burst days
so so
i learned it a lot through like base r
stuff
um
and so now i'm a hybrid um and and i see
i see discussions on linkedin are you
tiny burst or not i'm like you know what
it's like everything in life
use the best
that works don't box yourself in
uh you know same thing with python and r
i use both in fact i'm a huge fan of
reticulate i use it all the time now
um
because our markdown is the best way to
present
so
i'll mix and match
our python to do a lot of my
presentations using sort of a web-based
tab format in our markdown
um
and it just it just gives you so much
more freedom and and so i tell people
don't box yourself in
um
if you think about a
a carpenter you know
they have like four different nail guns
you know one for a different thing you
have three different saws it's the same
thing you know languages are tools
um
you know even knowing a little c plus or
you know other languages
it all fits together you will find that
one day you're going to reach for that
tool and use it when you least expect it
and as
so i know you're starting to build up
this new team as well so i'm curious
what's something that you're most
excited about
in terms of data science and building
this team
one of the things that
gets like i'm a big nlp person i think a
lot of people have found that out and
that is changing almost daily it feels
like uh you know just when i was getting
you know good at tensorflow 1.0 and then
2.0 comes out and that changes
everything and then
um
you know improvements in neural networks
and then all of a sudden transformers
come out and that changes the whole game
but
you got to be able to apply it and i
think that's one of the one of the
biggest things like
there's some people oh wouldn't it be
cool if if that's what your project
starts out as it's not going to be
successful especially in a business
environment um it's more about can you
solve somebody's problem
um
and and
about six months ago we were able to do
something with nlp which was take
all these fancy models and tools
um
weave them together with our markdown
and actually give my cx guy
a visualization tool of comments
and so
it ran it took all the comments ran them
through a bunch of different um
processes but at the end he had like
this three-dimensional interactive
visualization
that
color coded the comments by theme
uh it used dimensionality reduction to
get the first two and then one of the
scales was sentiment and you could just
spin this thing and flip around and find
out you know you read the clusters and
what people were saying and
uh
it was really interesting because it's
so easy to really see what's going on
now
and so that you know that was like a
really first
move for the for the bank for people to
see something
you know completely different that
they'd never seen before anything like
that
but with doing those things
is a challenge too
um
because
you got to teach people about something
that they've never seen before
and and a lot of people aren't
comfortable with that uh and especially
in you know sort of i'll call these
older traditional
uh industries like you know i think
about banking and insurance and some of
the other ones um
you know no one wants a revolution
they can't handle it and it's just too
much change but they can handle
incremental steps you know you give it
to them
a little bit at a time
and maybe in two years you'll find
yourself down the road a lot further
along and i think
you know that's the way you gotta you
gotta look at it with industries like
that it's a it's a marathon it's not a
sprint it's not gonna happen in
six months or you know
whatever whatever fast timeline you read
about a google a facebook snow and so on
you're not down we're not them
and sometimes it's about focusing on
the basics first like
data
the company before i was at
the bank we were in healthcare i was in
the healthcare industry
um
and
they formed a
analytics core analytics team and
everything else
we spent two years building a data
warehouse
that's what that's what they focused on
and it was the right decision
we hired data engineers and you know
getting everything so you have one
single source of truth
because the biggest way to lose
credibility with your executives
is you come in and say something and
show them some data and they say i saw
something else elsewhere and now you got
a problem
and
so so we focused on on making sure that
didn't happen and then you can actually
do the data science when the
data engineers are building your data
models and everything else then it's
easy like
you don't have you don't want people
writing
custom sql because everybody writes it
differently and do you get the right
results like the the
the importance of data engineering is is
not stated enough out there
because that is the ultimate foundation
what is that process look like so i know
you say you'd show them in incremental
steps but does someone come to you with
a question first or
[Music]
yeah so
it's all about like i said you know
solving that business case so somebody
says um
hey i got this server and a class one
because i did a year in market research
also um and kind of revolutionized that
in a way
um
they're like hey i have some survey data
can you analyze it for me
um
and so from there
to me
it's there's two aspects of it
you you're not going to do that much
machine learning in it which is good
there is a little bit you can do if the
survey is designed right but then it's
also just bringing better visualizations
and
like traditional and marketing as you
hear top two box
and i'm like no no no no you use all of
your data so
like uh
you know people
for a question you know they score you
one to five one to ten or whatever
you show that as a violin plot or
something like that that shows
the full distributions of everything
um
and people are wow you know i've never
seen that before
but at the same times you got to be able
to talk
you you got to be able to explain it to
what they're what they're looking at too
so i think
and that goes back to you can't give
them too much change at once because
you get hung up
explaining everything and you'll never
get anywhere
with the actual
you know what did we get out of this
survey kind of thing
rob i see that you raised your hand
yeah question hey hey brian nice to meet
you
um
if you are
just
starting a data team or you lead a small
data team what is the
timeline
that
you should be thinking of uh
i guess
in terms of
really tackling
big projects or like doing the things
that
executives or non-data scientists
probably think that a data science team
should be doing at an organization
i think you gotta you gotta tackle
the problems that are in front of them
right away
um
and
for instance i i think your timeline is
a is a year
but you got to deliver pieces along the
way so one of the things that we've been
working on
i've been there about a year
and early on it was
the customer lifetime value model
and
you know we're we're making our progress
through it and we're delivering the
first chance first real chunk which is
uh and it sounds like a basic part of it
but
we're actually gonna we've shown
everybody like these are the lifetimes
of all your segments um you know very
much like a survival analysis
because you can't do anything else with
lifetime until you know how long people
live
you know sort of like how long do the
customers hang around
but we've delivered
little pieces
every few months along the way to let
people know
we're still we're working at you know
we're giving them
the easy low hanging fruit while we work
on this big strategic
issue and that's the thing so
you have to have two timelines your you
have the strategic timeline which is
one to two years
and then you have your every few months
where you deliver just even if it's a
simple visualization
as long as it's different and as long as
it's useful
um
but
you know it all depends on
on the organization you're into
some organizations
can handle it faster um
and uh
you know others
you know it you know just depends on
what they're used to seeing i think so
because sometimes you get into just show
me what i've always seen
don't deviate and that's that's a
difficult place to be
but
the other thing one thing about my
career is
because it's a little older
i was often that first guy in doing data
science i was
six seven years ago i was the first
person in
this marketing research firm to
transform their
uh analytics from
manual excel small data
to algorithms and
understanding like
there are statistics involved and so you
can't just put an average out there and
assume it represents
you know the uh the data set
and
i think the first thing i did for them
was like a linear regression
um and it's you know i think to anybody
who works that's a data science
background to think yeah but that's
basic
but
not everybody uses it not you know
people don't use that every day
but it is extremely powerful tool
and
i think i would say along with that is
keep it simple if you can
like i know too many people
solving a problem first thing i want to
do is
run an xg boost model like throw all the
data into soup and let's run an xg boost
bottle but you're never going to be able
to explain that to somebody
and so
if you can do
a simple regression you know
even uh
if you think about a scatter plot as a
visual with a regression line through it
you've done a regression for that and
people get that and i think that's where
you start
um
my big thing that the marketing research
firm was was doing that
and also i brought text analytics in
and that's where i first got involved
we had i mean as a marketing research
firm
surveys and open ends are are your
lifeblood
and when i was talking to the people
they're like well
we take a sample of about 100 or 200 and
then we try to do it all by hand
and i was like so you're throwing out 90
of your data and then just kind of yeah
it's like well no
we can't do that
so so
uh
and the
thing about that role was
because i was the new person
you know people didn't know what i did
um you get a chance to define your role
a little bit
um
and that's why i say bring the bring
your data science to a traditional role
because you might be able to redefine it
along the way
and make it
what you want it to be
more than just i'm doing what
everybody's always told me to do that
that that's completely not me i'm not
one of those people that
even though i was in the military and
officer and everything i'm i even back
then i didn't do what everybody always
told me to do so
i definitely wasn't gonna do it then
um
and uh
you know
you're gonna get resistance and that's
okay
um
not everybody's going to take your idea
the first time
yeah
i really like that
point you made earlier about like people
don't really want a revolution right now
so you have to show them like
each step um
but i'm thinking about like the way
you're doing this today at the bank or
how you've done it previously in an
insurance like say it was text analysis
i think what
how do you go about communicating that
to people or like what are the the
people skills you've learned along the
way of of showing them these things
uh
you gotta start
really simple
and and i'll use an example of doing
that so
early on my career literally almost 20
years ago
in insurance
i was doing a commercial
property rating plan form
and the data didn't work for like
how much credit do i give somebody for a
deductible i mean think about that like
if i take a 500 deductible i get x off
and if i take a thousand
um and this was commercial property so
you're talking about
five thousand ten thousand million
dollar deductibles
data didn't work at all um
and so i was like all right i got to do
so you know failure isn't an alternative
here um
and i did something from my finance days
called
an option model
and
at the end of the day
an insurance contract is a call option
and
what a call option looks like there's
something called a payout function it
looks just like a hockey stick
so
you have a straight line and then when
you when the loss exceeds your
deductible the insurance company starts
paying and it's literally like i spent
six weeks describing a hockey stick
figure for people
uh
and explain just explaining the concepts
and
you know i'd go back and forth and
you know i'd show it to them five
different ways but i spent six weeks
just selling that idea without even
crunching a number uh it was selling a
concept
um
and
you just can't get frustrated like you
just got to be really open
um
and then at the end of that as is you
got to read people too like as you get a
little buy-in like you get the
acknowledgement hey i understand this
um
then you give them a simple example that
they they can work work on and i did
that like i took one of their accounts
and
um
you know with data that they had seen
from somebody else that's the other
thing is you got it you've got to use
something that they're comfortable with
um
and so i like we just had a broker in
and the broker explained here's the
standard deviation of your portfolio and
i was like yeah you remember that and
they were like yeah so
you keep
familiar it was very simple
until i you know
it took me
uh four or five months
to sell that idea from
i don't have any data to do this with so
we're kind of screwed at this point
and now i'm gonna now i'm gonna get
creative outside the box that nobody's
ever seen anything um
and i'm gonna have to figure out how to
sell it
and at the end of the day it's it's in
there it was filed in all 50 states and
um
[Music]
this whole methodology that i sort of
developed for and and i've talked to
i've run into people in my past
down the road they're like yeah i took
that idea like i have that rating plan
or i have that my plan and it's moved to
other people's companies so it's just
kind of funny that
uh
how that can happen along the way
that's great and and just a reminder for
everyone feel free to jump in live with
any questions you have or put them in
the chat or slido as well
but i'm happy to keep asking you
questions brian
is there any others
but i i know we've mentioned this before
on one of these but
and i saw maybe a post on linkedin
because i know you get really excited
about like nlp and actually like trying
new things and how do you balance that
with being a leader and not getting to
do
as much of what you may think is the fun
stuff
yep ah that's it you know so it's i just
had that conversation with my boss the
other day
it is a tough balance like so
i've always been and even even from the
days in the military like
you can't just be
a leader
um
and you can't and you can't just be the
doer either as as as a leader or manager
you got to figure out how to wage it
at my level you got to figure out how to
do both uh and i think i remember one of
those last ones like uh the one was like
she's like i don't work at my keyboard
anymore
um
and
i do still so i do both
um i also uh
do a lot of code reviews with my junior
guy
and it's hey you know
the code's not efficient and we kind of
walk through certain ways or have you
ever thought about doing this way
um
on the on the real exciting stuff
like i try to do like a little piece
somewhere
like like the nlp thing so so that whole
3d visualizer thing
it was one of these i had a couple days
in between all these other projects i'm
like i'm just going to bang this thing
out and you know sometimes you end up
working at night and all the other stuff
but i was like
it was part of it for me too
so um
you know that that was that was that was
the way i was able to really bring that
in and i was really excited to show a
lot of people about because it actually
opened doors for me um you know i hadn't
worked with transformers before
google universe's sentence encoder and
all these other things and the
visualization all of us just came to me
one night i was like oh we can do this
in 3d with sediment and because
everybody in nlp talks about sentiment
like okay that's fine what are you going
to do with it
um and for for us it was actually an
axis and a plot and allowed you to all
of a sudden take
thousands of comments
visualize visualism on this plot
was scaled by sentiment and it was like
ah
and then when we color-coded them by
themes and everything else you could
really see where the clusters of the
topics were
but going back to how do you balance it
it's not easy
you got to make an effort and at the
same time is
you got to manage upward
part of it is
you know working with your
manager said hey
you know
i feel like you know for the last x
amount of months
i haven't been able to deliver some of
these things that i know important
because we're focused on you know
fighting the fires
and so it's just having that
conversation so they understand
because you don't want to get to the end
of the year and somebody says what have
you done or why haven't you done this
like
that that's disastrous i think
for a lot of people um
so it's this constant checking hey this
is what we're working on you understand
this is important
um
and i actually keep a uh
a jira board for my team
i know most people use it for for you
know software development everything
else i use it for these are the projects
that are hot um
and it was funny um
freddie dranen who's a good friend of
mine i don't know if you've probably
seen him on linkedin and his big big r
guy he actually taught me it because uh
people were just throwing
like it began it became at one point
like the only thing that you can think
about is what's due in the next hour
and i'm like oh my god i can't handle
this like this is not this is just too
much stress um
and uh
he showed me how to do the board and so
because then you can show someone
i've got these 10 things you've added
11. it's not going to get done so which
one which ones are we moving and you
have to like
being a manager and a leader you have to
have those conversations like
or your people will get killed
and they will leave
um
and and that's just one i think that's
one of the biggest things i i took away
from the military is how to manage and
lead people that
you know when i i was fresh out of the
academy junior officer and next thing
you know like oh you're in charge of
people that got 15 16 years experience
and
you know understanding that dynamic and
how do you manage those people
is critical
and one of the things as a manager and a
leader is you have to be a buffer for
your people
you got to be the person that's between
them
and the rest of the organization
and i've seen
so much bad management over my career
where
where the manager is either an amplifier
and
you get a turnover just goes through the
roof
um
or or
that's the worst case if you're an
amplifier of all the noise out there for
people or you're just a pass through
which means you're not even
doing anything to deflect from
from your folks
and then
um
the expression that comes along with
that is you you can you can delegate
your
authority
but you can't delegate your
responsibility
so
if something goes wrong a project goes
wrong from one people that work from you
it's on you as the manager and the
leader you have to eat it you have to
own it you don't pass the blame
you know you can have a talk with that
person in private down the road
but when you're in that conference room
or whatever else
that's your responsibility you take it
uh
and so i i think
that's the part of leadership and
management that often doesn't get talked
about you know people like i organize
teams and i do all this kind of stuff
and
and code and everything else yeah but
there's a there's a there's a real human
responsibility pers portion of it that
it's just not taught i think that's
that's the biggest part like you can't
teach that in a traditional university
you can't go to a seminar on it
um
i mean for me i got it drilled into me
for nine years in the military so it's
not like something you'll learn
overnight
so how do you get better
at those things uh
if you're not in the military
one is
you get the your first axiom is
take care of your people
that's that's a
that's the first thing and so you got to
constantly ask yourself
am i taking care of my people
um
the the other
and another little i hate using somebody
sometimes but it's a really good
expression
so we used to say
managers do things right
leaders do the right thing
and so part of it is you're going to
have to
step in step out of your comfort zone as
a leader
is and that's one way to practice
and
but be smart about it you know it's kind
of like
i you know tell people you know i think
outside the box i live outside the box
um
but at the same time as i make sure i
don't get completely smoked too because
um
you you can't live out at the end of the
limb the whole time because someone will
cut it off on you and you will go
crashing down um
but
yeah so
how do you practice that you just gotta
find those small opportunities
um whether it's
um
and you usually find it when something
doesn't go right like i think that's
that's what really defines
uh people is when something just doesn't
quite go right
how do you handle it uh
and
the key is to not be re not be instantly
reactive
um and i'll be honest
when i was a lot younger i wasn't i was
i was wasn't that great at that part
like i would react right away
um
and uh
you know
i'm not gonna say i was an expert but i
but i was actually very good at making
sure my people were taken care of but
you know sometimes it was costly to me
i'll be honest um
you don't always win management doesn't
always you don't always look good in
management but
um
i could sleep at night and i think
that's the that was at the end of the
day as i felt
good comfortable with my decisions
and
my people liked me and
and
they expressed it
when you
when you mentioned like
okay well you have all these fire drills
that come in and i use jira and now you
can see how everything's organized do
you use some i can't remember what blog
post i was reading but someone mentioned
an intake request form like do you use
some sort of
requests from the the business like how
do those
questions get funneled into that process
we don't have a formal way to do that um
and
i don't want to go down that route
because it becomes
adding a layer of bureaucracy which i
absolutely hate
um
so a lot of it for me is yeah yeah yeah
we'll write it all down
and
then i'll ha again i'll have a manage a
meeting with my manager and we'll kind
of prioritize some of the projects
um
because you know part of the role is you
know i'm doing work for everybody else
but we got to fit everybody in a
priority queue and and
that's that's a
a common or a way to
when you have these like center of
excellence type um
data science teams versus i think
it's harder to do that if you're a data
scientist scientist embedded in a
a you know
you're the finance data scientist or
you're the ops data scientist
i think you can still do that you can
still manage it but
it's a little harder to be able to
prioritize people but at the same time i
don't want to get into this
fill this form send me a request i'll
figure it out
um
you know here's my sla for you
andrew i see you just came out and muted
do you have a question
yeah i mean i love the fact
that he talked about leaders and
managers
but uh for me i mean i was in a
situation where
uh
i'm in the leadership role i was taking
it on because i was trying to do the
right thing
and the manager he was like he was
trying to do it right
you know but
it it was like a conflict because i
didn't want to fudge numbers
you know that that it comes to that
integrity
right
so
yeah that that was a nice
remark i love that
yeah
you don't that's your your
those are harder ones and
you never do that like
because you can't get it back
once
once you lose that integrity or once you
go down that step like fudging numbers
and stuff
there's no coming back from it
um
it's sad i mean it's sad like especially
even now with with all this going on in
the healthcare
uh i think that's the of utmost
importance you know
trying to
align uh things right for the whole
country
yeah
and
i mean i've gotten into it with with
managers um
i mean when i was in the military i
actually told him that i was a
lieutenant which is pretty junior
officer told admirals where to go
um
because i wasn't going to do or or i've
told senior people no i am not going to
do that
um
and
i mean
in work environments i just
i've left jobs because of that you know
sometimes it's just
you just gotta walk away and and
yeah my career has had a lot of
companies and a lot of jobs and
everything else and sometimes it comes
down to stuff like that and i am not
going to be a part of that i'm not going
to hang around because
it will destroy you and
it won't really get you anywhere
correct and i mean hats off to you brian
there was just one manager who i worked
for he was in the military too so
i truly understand your
take on this
thank you
you're welcome
there's a similar
question that came in anonymously but do
you have any suggestions on how to have
a conversation with a manager who is an
amplifier or refuses to accept
responsibility
you have to find
a moment
when it matters
right so it has to be
again it's something has to go really
wrong
and you got to find that way to have
that conversation
um
my first job as an officer on a ship
my chief engineer and i
didn't get along like it was miserable
like everybody know it too
um
and so you know it was either i'm done
you know i'm six months into my career
for the next five years
gotta solve this
uh
and so i took a gamble and and knocked
on the door and said can i talk to you
and
we had that dif we had probably one of
the most difficult conversations and
this was so early in my career
but it turned everything around
um
but it was a risk i had to take
uh
and i think you can do you can do that
with
you can make that decision
yeah do you have that comment yeah knock
on the door and have that conversation
um
and
the other thing is if it's not going
well
and
don't stay in there for the fight like
don't stand there because you have to be
right or whatever else
you know you got to be able to know that
hey this isn't working um
and
but the best thing is coming off fresh
off a of a bad experience
or something like that is the only the
only way you'll be able to get there on
common ground to be able to talk about
it um
and and and
you know sometimes it
you just
you take responsibility for it too um
and that's a good way to start
start that conversation hey i know this
really didn't go well
this is what i felt um
and
you know
try to get the try to get discussion and
not
conflict
but it's not easy i'll be obvious you
know those
it's never easy
thank you
maybe um
switching gears a little bit i see
there's a few questions that came in
when you were mentioning how you use r
and python together
and rick i see you asked a question
about challenges and successes for using
the two together do you want to add any
additional context to that
so oh for me all right um i thought it
was to rick um oh it was it was it was i
sorry i didn't notice i was on mute um
yeah i was saying i was really happy
that you mentioned uh combining
different tools and using them uh to the
full effect in a single way i imagine
like i are in python and bass and tidy
burst uh i i i still don't understand
this this purism of like 100 base or 100
tidy person not just
doing the thing that works right i get
my people to always
however they intuitively understand it
as long as they get something done is
better than trying to get fraud and
spending days trying to get them to work
in one specific way so um i just
published this book with o'reilly the r
and python um together for the modern
data scientists and i was very happy to
hear that you're doing our python i was
wondering if you could mention um an
example where you did that and where you
really had a challenge because i think
it's something that is hard to convince
other people in the team or the managers
to combine languages um especially for
the support network um and also
something where you had a success in
combining r and python and if you've
ever used the python package the
rpi2 to go in the opposite direction if
you've had success with that
the easy one is i have not used archive
to go to the opposite go the opposite
direction so
um
one so i had this project at the last
company it was to do
time series forecasting for like 10
different metrics for leadership team
um
and
i loved r for time series but it wasn't
giving me
the visualizations that i wanted um
and maybe it's maybe it's the way i was
looking at like for instance
like
the whole back test model
um so you take your model then you back
test it on all your data and see how it
compares with with the existing data um
i had i had done a lot of work with
python time series
and it seemed right way easier to do
stuff like that
um
and i actually built a module that i
have on github a module that does all
sorts of time series functions for you
um using stats models and everything
else and so
um
i took the python for the time series
part
and
um r for the visualization side of
things yeah because
matplotlib just doesn't cut it and
and seaborne's okay
but
well there's some nicer packages there's
um there is one which is very similar to
gigi part two it has a funny and i keep
forgetting the name of it um but it
tries to emulate really even the syntax
of gigi part 2 and it's it's a a very
minimal version but it is something
um i have to look up have to look up the
name you can use it for a while um so
you you would say that python is better
for
time series
than r or was it only in this specific
instance would you have rather used r
it was in this specific instance because
i
again i had to convince people that
these models are accurate now how do you
do that well you show it to them you
show them hey here's the model
and
it was really cool because my boss had
to go explain it to the cfo
and so it was easy for him because they
could see
as as the model moves through time it
was actually learning and so you know
the first couple of data points you know
there's a lot of variants and then it
sort of hovers in eventually it begins
to pick up all little bumps and grooves
in the time series um so that
visualization piece of it um
and then
i used um
gg plot to do all the plots with with
ggplotly which is great because
you know one line of g one line converts
a ggplot into an interactive plot and
that's what this thing was
and then i wrapped it all up in our
markdown
um using the you know the dt um
package for for charts so people wanted
to export the excels and all this other
stuff
and it really
wrapped it all together
pretty nicely it's like we had this
little app that i would build every
month and it would show
here's this month's forecast
here's last month's and how it performed
and here's the months before because we
were doing three months out
um
and so they could see all three of the
lines against existing data and you can
see it also had the back test of the
model
um
and uh
the only the only way this was gonna get
done was between the two of them
otherwise i might have had some build
build some crazy
you know
app and you know i don't react or
something like that to get it to work
but our markdown you just knit the code
up and you know when plotly the next
thing you know you've got an interactive
application that
goes in the web i mean i mean i love
just making a shiny runtime in a
markdown document and not even using the
whole thing just having in this little
snippets and that's so incredibly easy
um but maybe i want to just as i decide
um because it sounds like the issue with
the r
thing was something that i sometimes
encountered which is that the tidy data
the long version is sometimes so
unintuitive
because it's such a machine
readable format than a human readable
format that um i i've had i've had one
case where a student i had had um
just tons and tons of data from brain
scans and just different regions and
tons and tons of different slides and he
had this massive table and he had to put
into tidy and it was like out of
millions of rows and very very long and
thin and he was like what what do you
think and then and then when he finally
when i got when i got him to understand
the pivot longer and white it was like
ah okay then and then everything clipped
and then he was able to do everything
immediately efficiently and i wonder
sometimes um you know you duplicate data
sometimes it which is a very unintuitive
weird thing to do because of just you
need to but for making the plot like if
you want the baseline to be on every
plot i mean maybe i don't know how to do
it correctly but i would then copy it
so that it's on every every facet of the
plot for example so that every section
is there um i'm sure there are better
ways of doing it so maybe is it was it
something like that is that why you
couldn't um
get the get r to do what you wanted with
the time series and it was much more
intuitive
had to do with how i was using ceramax
models which are
seasonal auto regressive interact
integrated moving average models
and it wouldn't allow me to literally
run the data back through as a back test
or at least
at the time i couldn't get it to work
very well
and uh
what's interesting on an aside a
different part of it is i actually gave
a talk at the bus and i use a groupon
reticulate
and one of the things i showed is to do
a simple
um facet plot in ggplot you can do it
four lines
to do that matplotlib it was like a
whole page of code
and i actually showed people you have to
write this much code
versus this much to get the same plot
um so so the so you know visualization
is key and i've actually used r in the
past actually in my first
job back like that that startup job to
do vector auto regression um
because we were forecasting
um
[Music]
our business using and it took in two
inputs it took in how many sales people
we had and then
you know using the time series of the
other day and it actually worked
extremely well like um
it was it was leads leads and it's
basically think about sales leads and
sales
you know those two series are highly
integrated
um and then we had an exit an extra
variable called how many people did we
have that day on the floor
and that worked beautifully like
uh the vars package and r vector auto
regression
uh
gave me the plots it took a little bit
to unwind it because sometimes sometimes
you get some weird um
data types
in our that that can be challenging like
lists
uh and
so
if you do the natural language
processing with r if you do some if you
do this um
frequency threshold count function it's
in the tm package
um what you'll find is that it tells you
it gives you a pair data
that's you know word
and it's frequency like so if you if
you're like like if you do text and say
um my phrase is customer service show me
all the terms that are correlated with
customer service but when it returns
that data type
it's
it's like a tuple that you can't unwind
and
yeah
you have to do all this one listing and
everything else and it's someone yeah
but
i wouldn't blame r for that i would
blame the person that wrote the packages
they weren't thinking about um using it
like one thing that i just um
stumbled upon was um different options
for
classic unix commands are different
um for doing the same thing are
different in different functions like
being recursive the the option letter
changes because and then i was watching
a youtube video and they were saying
well because they were made literally
written by different people and they
just didn't talk to each other so they
just didn't bother to think about
coordinating and making the um the
options that do the same thing have the
same name and you know that was way back
in the day and that's just a bad design
design system i mean the people think
people don't talk to each other there's
also design thing and if somebody makes
a package and they produce a terrible
output um i i think it's i blame on them
because they haven't thought about what
the user should do with this like yeah
and like the aggregate function um
the old the base are aggregate um
drove you nuts because you produced such
a terrible output and as a young student
trying to deal with it i i was like i
have to do so much work for this and you
know those days are gone because they
kind of have now better better syntax
and design associated with it so i don't
think that's an art thing i think it's a
design thing
yeah yeah it's it's it's it is it's a
package design thing um i had the same
problems way back with aggregate um
and you know subsetting and stuff like
that um
it was you know five six seven years ago
it was a challenge it wasn't a lot of
fun
um but this morning with the with the
unpacking the frequency things the guy
came up to me so i've been looked trying
to do that for a year
that's like well here's the code it
solves all your problems because that
that function is so valuable
um
that that frequency
um
you know basically shows the correlation
of words in your documents and
um it makes a very powerful plot like i
i always do that like when people say
custom experience or or i do it either
as a bi-gram or a trigram
show me all the phrases that are highly
correlated with it and you can see some
funny stuff like if you get a rich
enough text
you will see some funny phrases
um
[Music]
i see that um alyssa had asked about
some examples or use cases or good
examples of using r and python together
and unless i'm curious if there's
specific ones you were looking for i
mean so i i
i'm an old school bioinformatician
originally and then come data scientist
and um i
run a lot of trainings and hackathons
and things like that and so i really try
to be language agnostic and i'm always
talking about how cool it is that for
instance you can use r and python all in
an r notebook and the inverse that you
can use r and python in a jupiter
notebook as well
and everyone's always really excited but
then i can never give them good examples
like in the wild that have actually done
this right like most of the time if you
find a notebook it's all one language or
all the other languages i haven't i
haven't
i would love some examples to actually
be like see i'm not making this up
people really do this
um
so one of the things that that got me
down this route or actually i was i was
already down it and i i call it a tail
or two notebooks
um
because i was doing something for our
marketing guy several years ago
you know i was doing it in python
but you can't give somebody a jupiter
notebook
it just doesn't visualize
and i could have
wasted my time copying all the things
out making a powerpoint deck and
everything like that but i hate doing
that because now it's now you're into
this really manual and if you got to
redo it
so what i figured out was
that i could do my python
in our markdown
use my tabs
hide all the code and only show a couple
of key graphs and do the markdown to to
do like the slides
and he'll get exactly what i want him to
get because i actually gave him the
first notebook and i said look here
here here here and of course they don't
um
and it was totally confused so it's like
all right let me change this and so i
began to copy and paste and from jupiter
notebook into into our markdown um there
you know there was a learning process
there too because some things don't um
come across as easily they're just some
subtle differences um and then i knitted
it all up and nice and clean it's like
yes i could have just given him
literally like three slides with
commentary
but and i had just no desire to do it in
powerpoint i was like i'm not gonna go
down this route like it's solvable
um and i i do it
a lot for presentation because the
markdown presentation format
is the best out there that you know
there's nothing in python that's as good
so
so i think about it as
um
ours ours and our mark on us is just the
the best way
to present anything
um
and i always use the html format with
tabs so it makes it look like it looks
like a web page
um
and i i remember doing it so i was doing
an nlp
display when i was
at hanover insurance so i was text
mining all their claims
um and i was presenting to the executive
team
and
and it was in my html format so somebody
says like how do i print this out and i
was like you don't
and then the second the ea was like okay
um
because part of it when you do it when i
do it in that format
it's it looks like a web application and
that's what i was also showing like this
is the prototype to a web app
and you know see we have tabs and links
just like a web page does
and here's the functionality and here's
the display you're going to get
and so
it works extremely well at that and
i could probably release
uh
a portion of my little time series app
or at least some screenshots from it to
so people can see like hey this is this
is really just our markdown wrapped
around python
and ggplot visualizations
um
but
i was looking for the slides for your
meetup presentation real quick but i
couldn't
find them
but i know that i will so i can share
those too alyssa
yeah
um
but if anyone else has examples too it'd
be great to share
those in the chat
yeah um
i you know as rick was talking like
what's interesting is my junior data
science that i work with now he uh he
started using r
and then
he switched everything to python and now
he won't use r and i was like
you can't be that rigid
and i just told him i said that you're
going to find out that
um
you just can't be that rigid and
uh
you know there's guy out there matt
dancho you know he is um
big our guy
[Music]
incredible teacher
um
and it's really like
if i get these quick things like some
somebody wants a couple of slides or a
couple of visualizations with some data
tomorrow i'm doing that in r and that's
why i tell they got a workspace i said i
don't care i am do this is going to be
an arc so i can bang this out in about
a couple hours and
you know i've got all i've got a huge
amount of base code
it's faster
i can knit it you know it's just like i
just told him if i am doing anything on
a quick hit scale it's going to be an r
now if we're looking to build up this
giant app or something like that i may
switch it over down the road um
because that's the other thing you run
into like
i t people
they know what python is they probably
don't know what r is
and we actually ran into this weird
situation at hanover rit people wanted
everything converted from
python or r into java i was like i don't
think so
like
someone came up with there's a i guess
h2o is able to do it because that's
written mostly in java so it's able to
create the
the jar files and stuff and i was like i
know what that's not happening um
ryan as we get to the top of the hour
here i know a few people have to jump
off so just wanted to ask you if people
have follow-up questions is linkedin the
best way to get in contact yeah it's
probably the best way um
and uh
yeah
share the link in the chat too
um but if it's okay brian there's a few
more questions that came in you go a few
okay awesome um melissa i see you asked
a quick question on the name of the
package that brian was referring to
on the bigrams or
trigrams did you want to add anything
melissa
no just hoping to um circle back and see
what that was called it sounded like it
was pretty handy for
nlp yeah it's embedded in the tm package
um
and
i have the presentation from that
from that talk we did at rachel that the
user at the user conference way back at
slalom
um
we could probably post a link to github
on that and it's just there's a ton of
code in there melissa
okay it'll show you how to do
pretty much anything you could ever want
um
with with tex mining and r
and uh
but it's it's in the tm package and it's
the problematic one is to find um
was it fine frequencies i think it is um
where you where you enter a
term
and a a correlation threshold and then
it finds all the correlated terms um but
there's a couple examples in there with
it with the code how to unwind it and
everything else
um
i'll either get rachel that link to it
or we'll figure out a way to post
to repost that presentation
i really appreciate that thank you all
definitely and most i can i can try and
send that to you directly as well
i have to reticulate one two rachel
where we did um
you know the side-by-side comparison
what does it take to get them working
together and
just because i know there's a whole new
you know people haven't seen
that but but
it's a lot of hints and tips on how to
get how to
um use reticulate with python and i
think i even did a uh
you can use uh pi torch in uh in our
markdown and and
we did the uh
the neural network training on in our
markdown too and it kind of shows you
all the output
um
definitely
yeah we can we can we can share those um
i think so i
think kevin you had a question around
how brian enjoys learning new things and
what's the next big thing you'll be
looking to progress your knowledge in
so
there's two things that i have two work
streams in my life one is fun and one is
work
like literally so i take courses that
will help me
with my career get a better job um so
i've enrolled in pi image search and i'm
learning computer vision from really the
basics you know you start with
image processing because yeah i mean
i've done this convolutional neural
network that we can figure out cats and
dogs and all that stuff but
that's not where the work starts so
that's that's like
one part
and as a kid
growing up i wanted to make games on an
apple ii plus computer that had
i mean if you think about basic and
computers back then i mean
at 48k of ram so i learned assembly
language to do it um and made a little
missile command game so i'm actually
relearning assembly language now um
it's really fascinating so i i took a
first course on how to design a cpu from
scratch
um
and it was just mind-blowing and and
really opening like
you you design your first memory gate
and nand gates and things and and at the
end we have a working like 16-bit
computer
and then assembly language
and i am about to take a class in
assembly language to build games on an
atari 2600 i know it's like wicked old
school
but
it's fun like
and it really is like learning assembly
language really teaches you the guts of
how a computer works
um
and so that's my little
fun project along the way um
and it's it's it's happening slowly in
phases like i said i did the cpu first i
took one level of um assembly language
refresh wow
um and now i'm on like two and three i
got two more to come through it to make
some games
awesome i i know hugh had to to drop but
i really like this question as well um
but he asked do you have any tips for
communicating complex issues through
simple or easy digestible techniques
um
one is
find the simplest
visual for it first
like
um
my one of my chemistry professors
packing college used to always talk
about it call them football player
analogies like the analogy's so easy
even a football player can understand it
um
and so and it's got to be visual so
think about it as your first step is a
simple visual don't try to put
everything out there at once
um
and and that's that's really that you
know find the simplest visual you can
give them to start the conversation
you don't have to sell it all in one
shot
and is
that usually through like our markdown
or how do you share that yeah i actually
do that now as much as i can um
like i did the whole uh
the design for what a uh
an nlp application would look like
processing our claims notes and
like it was little a
almost like
flow charting diagrams and things in our
markdown
and people could easily follow it like
here's an example of a bigram you know
and stuff like that you know this is why
we use
one of them was why do we use mongodb
for this rather than a regular one and
things like that where you can show
very simple concepts that solve the
problems
and explain why you're what problem
you're solving and i think that's the
two things with that visual
the visual should explain what it is but
it also to explain why it solves your
problem
some people just say why
yeah
and let's see i see there are a few
other questions i just want to make sure
i get to and not keep you over too long
ryan but
there was an anonymous question that was
is it possible to practice leadership
skills in all or most organizations or
are there any
work environments that are too broken to
develop as a leader
uh
i think you can in every organization
um no just looking at one of my little
kitties is trying to get out of my
office here
so i never said make sure the door was
open so she could get out
i don't know if an organization is too
broken um
uh
i mean i've been able to practice in any
organization
um
some of them i've only lasted one year
though so
you know you got to take that you can
take that with a great assault so i know
i've there have been a lot of company
there have been a handful of companies
don't say a lot that i've only spent one
year with them for whatever reason
either they've made it clear that
i don't fit
i don't have a career or there's no way
i'm ever going to convince them that you
know
data science or something is the way to
go even though even though i'm making
results for them
they're not buying they're not
recognizing the strength of it and so
sometimes
you know your answer is to find
somewhere else to go um
and i think is
is data science
people if you're on top of your game it
shouldn't be that hard to do if that's
the decision you have to make
so thank you
and we do appreciate cats on the data
science hangout as well if you want to
look at the academy
no she slipped out the door
um one other question too i want to ask
you brian and trying to ask this every
week but are there
certain like podcasts or things that you
read that you would recommend to others
uh
i've g well one of the things is
i'm actually a reasonably
uh
active person on stack overflow so i get
this i get stack overflow weekly
um i get
another one is
the super data science team
uh they sponsored this thing called
ds go
it's a big
networking career fair but
and they get all the best people they
get the ben taylors the matt danchos
um pretty much anybody you know
kate's track know um
any major data science person that
you've seen on linkedin they seem to be
able to get them to do something
so i sort of follow that
um
it's more like i follow people versus
like
blogs so again
the super data science team always
brings on interesting people
uh
and the end and i've you know i
regularly read the end video um because
i get the i get a specialized user thing
for that just to
keep my fingers in the latest ai stuff
cool
and i would definitely recommend
following brian because i feel like i've
met so many people from seeing your
comments on other people's posts
[Laughter]
it's
i i have to say i really like linkedin
like the funny thing is i am i am no
longer on facebook i haven't been on
facebook for almost 10 years now
uh i've
got what it rid of twitter about five
years ago
because the only reason why i had it was
so i could do a dev account and scrape
twitter
feeds for marketing
but i just got tired tired of just it
felt like a cesspool
and it was kind of depressing so i you
know got rid of that but linkedin is
still to me
a great environment and
you know follow people read
people post some amazing stuff when you
find out there is a a probably select 10
people out there that are fantastic to
follow along with
um
and
i can pull i'll put i can pull a list
for you and in the in the uh
oh wait this isn't through meet up so
i'll i'll have to get you something that
you can post like
yeah
we're gonna figure that out like uh
making a landing page so that we can
share resources with everyone and
have a home base
yeah cause there's this guy i think his
name is tanner tanner and r something
like that he posts a lot like amazing
stuff um obviously ben taylor is the
philosopher of a.i
um matt danicho is fantastic for like
how do you be applied
um yet kate she's her date her dedicated
feed
is is really good um
i'm trying to think of some of the other
people out there but there's yeah
there's a gel reese is another one
um
definitely
yeah because not everybody's as active
as some of these people so you'll get
like a regular it's almost like you get
a regular um
sort of feed of the information from
them that's
that's useful and interesting
for sure yeah i've been starting to see
a lot more um
maybe it's based on what i'm looking at
but more about like data storytelling as
well
that is
that is probably one of the most
important things
a person can learn as a data scientist
how to tell a story
um you can't just
you know the presentation that has a
million charts and and and not we have a
story together in fact that's one of the
things that i'm teaching my junior guy
like
how to put
slides and how do you title us a slide
and
um all these little things so that
you're telling a story
um
like i used way back when i used to work
at liberty um
i used to do a lot of work for our
ceo
and we'd come in with a powerpoint deck
need to literally just flip through it
like a cartoon you know
and look for the back slide
so
um but what i made sure is that if you
flip through it slow enough and all he
read was the headline on each thing he
would have a storyline
but data storytelling is
it's it's everything because if you
can't tell the story no one's going to
pay attention to it
that's a new podcast i just found it i
think it was storytelling with data
i think i've seen that i've seen a
post with that yeah
um just want to check if if anyone has
any other questions and make sure that i
didn't miss anything that was on slido
or the chat
try and count five seconds i'm really
bad at silence but
[Laughter]
thank you so much brian for for jumping
on and sharing your insights with us
really appreciate it and
thank you all for joining too
thanks for the invite rachel and thanks
for everybody for tuning in and listen i
appreciate that
and brian will be at a meet up soon we
still got to figure that one out right
yeah we still got the marketing one and
yeah and there was one there was one
although we're going to do too so
awesome
well thank you brian have a great rest
of the day everyone
you